so this is what I my postdoc was all
about actually the first experiment I
did was to remove foxels and then induce
senesis and the cells died so that was
the end of the positive project let me
put it on the Shelf until later we
thought wait a minute this is maybe a
great way of of killing senescent cells
right um
so hello and welcome to the cheeky
science show where in this video I had a
great conversation with Peter the Kaiser
associate professor of senescence and
cancer and aging at UMC Utrecht who is
also at the same time an entrepreneur
and founder of Clara biotech where they
are focused on senescence and sonolytic
peptides which we'll learn more about
during our discussion so hi Peter thank
you for joining me today and welcome to
the cheeky Science Show
my pleasure thank you for having me so
um I've brought you once a day because
we have a lot of overlap in our
interests in particular on cellular
lesson Essence and so I thought just for
a fast question I just was wondering
what got you into senescence in the
first place and would you be able to
provide a sort of description of what to
you cellulose in essence is
to start with the most difficult
question in the entire field let me take
one step back how I became interested in
the first place that was actually
because of my PhD work which at the time
was on cancer
and at the time in 2008 uh it the idea
was that if you have cancer cells that
are apoptosis resistance maybe you could
still treat cancer by pushing them
towards senescence
and at that time it became interested in
the secretory phenotype which just had
just been discovered so senescent cells
secrete a range of
pro-inflammatory factors mainly and then
it was identified that these are
pro-aging
right and then the idea was well maybe
then we should not push cancer cells
into senescence but we should actually
try to target senescent cells and clear
the body of those senescence so that is
about a decade ago a decade and a half
ago when I became interested in the
field and then your more difficult
question
what is the definition of synthesis I
actually have a very controversial slide
and I usually start my presentation to
which that which is that there's no such
thing as senescent it's in essence it
does not exist because we all use
different biomarkers so of course the
concept exists the cells that become
extremely damaged they stop to
proliferate and it starts secreting
factors to the environment but that's
about as much as is true right because
some cells have uh B16 the other ones
have p21 not that others have letting B1
loss but neither and some secret factor
a some secret factor B so actually the
goal of my word is to figure out what
are the different kinds of certain cells
and how are they problematic in
different diseases so yeah
exactly yeah so I think obviously I
listened to your talk at the most recent
um senescence conference which was great
by the way
um and as you mentioned there's so much
heterogeneity in senescence and it's
hard to and there's also different ways
in which a cell can become lessons so
um I guess another thing that maybe we
don't really have the answer yet but do
you have any thoughts as to what might
be the main inducer's of senescence in
the body
in the body good question because in the
lab we know but in the body is a good
question so of course there's this is
speculation right so it's the theory is
that it's a lifelong accumulation of
damage
um so UV exposure uh improper diet lack
of exercise you know just by using
oxygen
constituents inside cells are oxidized
and that those need to be replaced or or
repaired and if that doesn't happen we
think that you know early in life that
all happens and later in life it's a you
know it's an exponential growth curve so
we see we see more and more damage being
built up
on top of that the immune system becomes
weaker with age so it's a crosstalk like
more buildup of certain cells because of
DNA damage and protein damage and lipid
damage
and a reduced clearance to the immune
system so that leads to the net result
at that around age 60 65 we see an
exponential increase of decent cells in
most tissues in the human body yeah and
what like um what are the major diseases
that are sort of linked with senescent
cell presence
yeah that's also an extremely good
question there are almost too many that
is also why I think we need a better
definition right so uh we have
academic projects and also have
commercial projects but academic
projects in the in the musculoskeletal
area
neurodegeneration we know cardiovascular
disease has it aneurysms
um liver fibrosis lung fibrosis almost
every organ kidney acute and chronic
kidney disease almost all diseases
especially if they're chronic
have some component of senescence
um at least that's by correlation so
senescent cells are often present at the
disease that doesn't mean it's always
causal
but in Mouse models yeah there's just
about 40 plus papers by now showing that
if you remove senescent cells mice do
better for all of these diseases so it's
a bit too much
if you ask me and that's why I think we
need a better definition of what type of
senescence do you find in which disease
because
aneurysms are for instance caused by
proteases mmps whereas in cancer they
are important but interleukins in the
pro-inflammatory effects are more
important so different diseases
different types of senescence in my
opinion and I'm not going to say one
disease is better than the other or
worse than the other I should say
because they're all they're all bad but
um yeah there are many yeah exactly and
although there are like I guess most
food differences in like different types
of senescence one sort of protein that's
important to most types of senescent
cells is the protein p53 which I know
that we both have interest in so would
you be able to give a sort of beginners
introduction to p53 and uh maybe
explaining how it relates to senescence
absolutely so yeah b53 is in essence a
very good protein right so cells become
damaged p53 is activated and the cells
are told to stall their proliferation
and repair
that in other cases if the damage is too
extreme uh cells can die because of p53
Activation so it's it's what was
originally coined as the guardian of the
genome right so actually there are more
Guardians of the genome but this was the
very first one
um and then it depends which other
proteins or or cofactors bind b53 what
the outcome is of p53's activity so in
senescence you're right p53 is activated
however we now also note if you
hyperactivate p53 internet cells you can
kill them so it seems like that there's
the bell-shaped curve or the The Good
the Bad the Ugly you need intermediate
levels of p53 for a cell to survive if
there's none you get cancer right
because you need it for cell cycle RS if
you have too much cells die if you're in
between you can either repair or sinest
let's say no
exactly yeah so um I think yeah I've
seen a lot of evidence
um so you kind of alluded to the point
of senior let it so things that can
trigger this lesson cell to also die and
that seems like a lot of them work by
actually trying to manipulate the phds
for activity levels and so um I know
that you contributed to a paper that uh
published about a peptide that
interacted an interaction of p53 with
this other protein called Fox A4
um so I was just wondering if you could
provide some sort of background context
to how you made this discovery and how
that actually triggers the senescent
cell to die
yeah yeah so my PhD work was on these
functional proteins but not in
senescence so it was on insulin
signaling and oxidative stress signaling
so foxos are were known to be important
in aging because uh worms and flies that
have foxes hyperactively longer for
instance so uh vice versa in cancer
cells oftentimes there's something wrong
with insulin akt signaling and the
foxtails are down targets there then
regulated so my background lies in
foxtels
then when I started to become interested
in senescence and especially the
secretory phenotype being deleterious at
least that was the idea I started to
look in the promoter regions of these uh
secreted factors and we found found that
almost all of them have a functional
binding site
so then we thought well maybe if we now
remove fuxos so there are three of them
one three and four don't ask me why they
they skipped number two and that's
because it's only existed frogs for some
reason so if you remove all three Fork
cells maybe you can blunt the secretory
phenotype so this is what I my postdoc
was all about actually the first
experiment I did was to remove Fox house
and then induce senesis and the cells
died so that was the end of the positive
project let me put it on the Shelf until
later we thought wait a minute this is
maybe a great way of of killing
senescent cells right um okay and then
we started to think uh well how could
that be and we had already I had already
discovered at around the same time that
foxes in p53 could regulate p21 well B21
is a p53 Target so I decided to look
well maybe they physically bind to one
another and indeed they did especially
under the conditions of DNA damage so
long story short
um that is a long story but since
function p53 bind one another and they
seem to be focused important for
maintaining the viability of silicon
cells I decided to make a peptide that
looks like foxo and that could then
hopefully compete with the natural
endogenous levels of foxo and then steer
p53 wave from from p21 towards cell
death that seems to be the case so with
this peptides that we made
I see you and so um we've spoken about
hydrating fancy in senescence and so is
this box so important and like you
mentioned DNA damage but serious
specific context why this might be more
effective than other types of nursing
cells I absolutely think that's the case
yes so I think there are types of uh
senesis caused by protein stress and or
even sterile senescence right so if you
have chromatin remodeling you get p16
expression but not necessarily A SAS for
instance so
we don't fully understand yet for which
types of senescence these Peppers work
we do know
that if you have a what we call scarring
that means that you have scars on the
DNA meaning DNA damage marks persistent
chronic large clumps of DNA damage
markers merged with what we call PML
bodies so if if you have those two fuse
to one another it's a particular type of
senescence and that is the one we can
kill this is what we call scar senescent
cells um
and that doesn't mean we can kill every
senescent cell for instance
by by oncogenic grass that seems to have
a very strong Pro survival component I
think in general it's much harder to
kill such cells than scar damage
senescent cells but these are all things
we are still looking into
yeah I'm talking about
um different sensitivities to
different that 2017 paper there's a
graph that shows how if you pre-treat
some cells in culture with interleukin
when Alpha and beta some of them become
more sensitized to treatment do you have
any like explanation as to why or how
that might be the case
yeah this is one of my favorite
experiments actually because we they're
still senescent cells right so
um in essence we didn't change them but
we just added some of the SAS factors
which then you know gives some sort of
feedback or feed forward Loop depending
on how you look at it
indeed if you give one of the main stats
factors il-1 alpham beta uh the cells
almost all die with this peptide vice
versa if you block io1 signaling then
then the majority of cells are not
targeted by these peptides so something
even though they're still senescent
cells it strongly determines the outcome
of treatment
and why that is my there's this
speculation at this point there are some
reports showing that Iowan can activate
p53
so then you can argue that you know more
io1 means more phosphorylated
hyperactive p53 therefore more Target
for your compound of interest that could
well be the mechanism of action but
these are all things that we're still
looking into as well you know yeah I see
and so like going back to the mechanism
of action
um the way that this peptide works is it
kind of releases p53 and so then it
makes it
um like how yeah because I know like
obviously I studied previously Facebook
is regulation and activities very
complex anyway but it's the idea it's
sort of Alters the ptms of PVC throw
like um how exactly does it then induce
cells f as opposed to
um maintaining those senescent States
yeah uh so you would think that you need
a transcriptional activity of p53 but
that's not the case at all so that's how
it started right we had an effect of p21
so we thought okay maybe if you remove
p53 then you do not have p21 and it
moves to box block and all these bh3 Pro
hypotonic produce it's not the case
because actually we know that the
peptides work even better if you have
mutants b53 so what we now know
is that mutant p53 develops an open
conformation so there are antibodies
that can recognize this open versus
close conformation and there's this this
binding domain that the second trans
activation domain or top two it's called
it's inside the pocket of the protein so
if you have mutant beef sweet it
actually is more loose and the compounds
can actually access it better now you
don't affect the PTM so the percent
rational modifications of p53 by this
better as far as we know but the with
the consequence of binding is that you
get nuclear export
so by binding the music or wild that p53
that is false formulated you you get an
export to the mitochondria and there you
seem to be getting a puncturing of the
yeah two backs back and uh release the
side concealing apoptosis so
you need to post translational
modification first of b33 otherwise you
would kill all cells equally because all
cells have b53
but you need to have a modified form
usually that's locked away safely inside
the p53 right but if you have mutant p53
or if it's extremely heavily
phosphorylated then it opens up and then
the compass can access and that's what
happens in these scar cells or scarred
cancer cells oh I see and I say um for
my first you don't know so previously
commonly mutated then cancers
um I think it's actually the most
commonly mutated Gene in human Cancers
and so therefore I guess there's a lot
of potential applications of this
peptides for cancer Therapeutics is that
is that right
yeah that is actually now what we're
going after so this is also a little bit
uh a deviation of how it all started
initially we thought like I said if you
have cells that have these DNA scars
then inside those female uh DNA damage
marks you have a lot of p53 Foxhole
complexes we determine the
three-dimensional structure and they're
very close together
so indeed diseases where you have these
scarred cells where our first targets
and then later my PhD student at the
time Diana put ahead identified it if
you have Newton p53
then almost all of them have these cars
so as soon as you have mutant pv3 you
get higher levels of p53 it's opened up
it's more accessible and indeed now we
see that a lot of mutant p53 types of
cancer
in vitro or in 3D cultures can
beautifully be eliminated so this is I
think what we're going to go after first
now
interesting I
I was just wondering if you could
explain like in terms of the translation
of these cell penetrating peptides
obviously that's very different to the
more I guess conventional use of small
molecules so uh what kind of advantages
and maybe disadvantages
um come with using this approach
yeah
um right so websites are a relatively
large and also new if you will class of
drugs right so small molecules have a
good name peptide originally had a bad
name because Normal peptides are made
with L amino acids so and they're in
stable so if you put them in plasma in
the blood they're degraded extremely
fast our peptides are made of D amino
acids and we reverse the sequence so
they're called the Retro inversified
um so the the downside of peptides is
stability
potential immune reaction because you're
injecting a piece of a protein so you
can get an immune response but we we
mitigated that because we made them
self-penetrating and we see that within
40 46 hours it's all cleared from the
blood they're taking up inside cells
because of the trick we used and because
of that D retro diversification they're
also very stable so there are all sorts
of arguments against peptides that we
overcame with these specific
modifications so that's not like we did
this overnight right the first
generation was in 2010. and then 2011
the second generation 2017 we published
the third generation and now we we
actually uh we have the fourth
generation and are making the fifth
generation so we we still keep on
progressing and keep on learning as well
yeah and so uh this work is now being
um developed further at your the company
uh clear about attack is that correct
yeah okay so um
the Third Generation episode third
generation it was all academic and then
we just said well now we need to
professionalize this a bit more so we
need to get people on board and know how
to do structural biology so we actually
made the 3D structure of p53 of the
domain where it binds and we we return
by NMR how the peptide's Blind and then
of course you can optimize it in a much
more intelligent way than just looking
at the sequence which is what I did
until that point
I see you and so um would you be able to
elaborate a bit on um what you're doing
with the company and um why you see
potentially uh you apply this this
pepsides
yeah
so uh again of course if you have a
company you have more people
collaborating than competing in
essentially as they may sometimes have
in science also
it's interesting that in science
sometimes you have the the thinking that
industry is evil and you should stay
away from conflict of interest but the
funny thing is that in Industry we need
to repeat the same experiment over and
over and over again because yeah it all
needs to be super reproducible otherwise
you can never gonna go to to human
beings right so the benefit of doing it
in a company is that you have these
different expertises all working towards
the same goal so we have a team of
structural biologists that made the 3D
structures then yet the molecular
biologists that do the um the cell based
essays then we have a team of mouse
experts that are you know fully into
looking at toxicity pharmacokinetics all
the kind of code boring stuff which in
Academia you would never publish in the
paper but you need it for going to Yuma
so we need to know when does the
compound become toxic and then you need
to go at least 10 steps lower then fold
lower
and that's then where you need to do
your efficacy experiments at which in
academic papers you rarely see people
just use one dose and you see an effect
you publish it in the high ranking
journal and then you you run away
so I think the benefit of a company is
that it's all very structured and the
downside of course that you have less
freedom because you know yeah you work
towards a goal so it's less freedom to
operate but I think within um we hope to
be in the clinic within 18 to 24 months
because now we have the developmental
candidates two peptides and there we
have efficacy with we did all the talks
pharmacokinetics Etc and mice now we
have to go to uh making the large batch
that will eventually be used in humans
and then do some further top studies so
I'm very excited about that uh yeah 18
to 24 24 months just to go you know yeah
for sure I will say saw some recent news
articles that you received some more
funding for the company as well so that
seems like yeah super well congrats to
you on that and I'm excited to see uh
where it goes to
yeah that's not enough to do clinical
trials but it's at least enough to uh
you know to do all the the prep work
let's put it that way so we will need
much more money if we really wanted
those human beings but let's uh hope for
it and how long would these trials take
um like after yeah
this one was excruciatingly long right
so hopefully the phase one trials they
usually say well you need to do what is
called a three plus three step up at
least that's traditional so you do three
patients and then if they don't show
toxicity you do three more three more
three more and that takes about 12 weeks
per cover so hopefully you can do this
in half a year to a year and then you
can start doing your efficacy phase two
trials and another two years and then
you have to do a multi-center phase
three trial so that may be another three
years or so so by the time you have
Market approval or a five to ten years
down the road
yeah unfortunately that's how long drug
development takes but you need to start
sometime at some point
um no exactly yeah I'd say for you like
um initiating this company and the
development of the fox A4 peptides was
that did it feel like a natural
progression or like because obviously as
you said there's obviously being an
academic is a very different setting to
moving into industry and the
complications and new knowledge about
what things I don't really know about
about running a company and so how did
you make that uh progression
yeah I think it actually is exactly what
you say it was very natural because in
2004 when I started my PhD I wanted to
be as fundamental as possible I just
enjoyed research I did not have any
translational ambition at the time until
I did my postdoc in San Francisco Bay
area which is around Silicon Valley
and I like I said I was always raised
but to stay away from companies and
Industry and just do fundamental
research
until people pointed out you know
industry is not evil I think you are
evil if you really have something that
works and you think it can actually cure
diseases you have an obligation
to bring it to the clinic and you cannot
say a big Pharma has to do it because
they don't understand and they they will
not do it
and initially I did not listen to that
you know I was raised you know stay in
Academia and I still very much enjoy
Academia but I thought well why not why
should I not start a company to try to
do this
because in the U.S many professors have
companies right that tried to valorize
their research which in Europe is
becoming more common but at the time it
was not so usual
um yeah so I I undertook it and then we
had several many many trouble uh you
know struggles getting this off the
ground until in 2018
uh in Utrecht where I'm right now they
were very excited by the whole idea they
said we this is where I also did my PhD
so they knew that we we had you know the
new quality we were bringing let's say
and I said well we also think you should
really you know try to get this into
clinical trials so they were very
supportive
and they said we we you know help you
with fundraising and uh yeah we found
investors and then we we got going
and as well do you hope honestly it
seems like clinical trials is the the
primary or like then the the first aim
to achieve with the fox say peptides but
do you see potential for maybe
developing other self-penetrating
peptides um generic approach yeah that's
the absolutely the case which I I always
tell people it's not so difficult to
make these peptides as a you know I'm
not a chemist that's also the reason I
do peptice also because of my background
as a molecular biologist I understand
amino acids and I understand charges of
amino acids I I'm not a chemist so I
don't know how to make Benzene rings and
whatever so
um you can do it yourself right so if
you know protein protein interaction
that you think is bad and you want to
break it that's easier to do right it's
easy to break things it's not so easy to
restore things that's what I've
experienced but we've made several
self-penetrating peptides for other
projects for colleagues and also a few
others in for clearer for instance
and one of them that I'm very excited
about has nothing to do with clearer but
it's against an oncogene like oncogenic
grass now we can actually Target that
it's pretty cool so
um yeah I imagine the possibilities of
if you just are able to break protein
protein interactions I'm sure you have
another favorite one you can always look
into making a peptide it's fun to do
and even if it's only for an academic
exercise right you don't always have to
commercialize everything but it's it's
quite
fun to play with these peptides I would
say cool yeah and also the the rest
sounds super interesting because I know
um that it's one of the proteins that's
been very hard to drug and it's actually
manipulation activity
so that's really cool
um and so your approach to developing
the this as analytic peptides kind of
had a very rational approach to it you
looked at the biology looks at the fox
say proteins and you like the signs
um the peptide that would actually
Target the proteins you're interested in
and so that is in quite a bit of
contrast to some of the others analytics
um or the naturally occurring compounds
that have been discovered that we still
don't really know how they work so what
are your thoughts on this analytic
fields in general
yeah that was a bit uh amusing to me
that I think to this day we are still
one of the few if not the only compound
that was actively designed or what it
does right most others were repurposed
or screened but you know there's nothing
wrong with that but it's
um it's just interesting that we started
all the way from the other end right so
um what do I think of that I think
um I have I don't know about questioning
the satinum because
the southern is supposed to be a sarc
inhibitor and questioning we don't
really know how it works so
out of all the papers you see out there
they also conveniently do not address
this which annoys me because then I
think yeah but you know show some old
Target effect here so they never do this
um it's a bit different from the for the
bco Inhibitors there I think it's quite
well known
how they work there they they work to
inhibiting BCL W and Excel not so much
bcl2 and
um if you know how they operate you can
also optimize them right because quests
in the certain if they're just the first
compounds these are not these have never
undergone actual development
and where's our peptides like I said we
are now in the fourth generation we we
designed many of them and failed
miserably so and now we're going towards
the fifth generation it's not like we
just made one in each generation right
so
um yeah by by knowing how they work you
can improve them which I think is hard
to do
um for these compounds that were just
picked up during screening
yeah exactly and so I so so far we've
kind of spoken about senescence as being
a sort of a bad thing
um for the body but we also know that's
an Ethics is important for things like
wound healing and in fact
um as was discussed in the conference
and has been published some of these
secretive proteins such as um
interleukin sex seem to be able to
um activate uh nearby cells to sort of
repel
um and replicate and basically replace
the damaged cells in cases such as wound
responses so um how does that play into
this idea of developing sonalytics
yeah this is of course a very important
point but I always compared to let's say
a drug addiction you know if you try
something once it may be great but the
more the longer you try it the more
addicted you become and the the worse it
becomes right so the same with a lot of
these SAS factors almost all of them
have an acute benefit and that's also
why senescent cells have an acute
benefit in wound healing if you remove
some Nestor cells from an open wound the
wound will still close but it takes
longer
the difference is When Things become
chronic right so if you have a lot of
you get the boy who cried wolf if you
constantly have cells it constantly
secrete a little bit of il-6 at some
point neighboring cells start to say
well you know forget it there's this
cell again right so yeah like I said the
bike ride wolves it will be ignored and
this becomes problematic during aging
but also cancer because the immune
system at some point
starts to ignore these clusters where
there are many synonyms of cells and if
there are aggressive cancer cells yeah
that you just get a buildup of of cells
that will block the immune cells from
killing those cancer cells so the idea
is that senesis is beneficial in an
acute setting during development
right the invagination of your fingers
we usually see senescent cells and then
they need to be removed and die and then
you get the uh your fingers to be formed
at least in mice I'm not sure about
humans but advice this was true or
during wound healing those are the
benefits of senescent cells other than
that I'm of the opinion that there are
no good aspects of suggesting cells
right they're just a leftover because in
evolution we were never supposed to
reach Beyond age 40 let's say because we
were supposed to get children and see
them get children and then we were
biologically Obsolete and when do we get
senescent cells yeah we get them but
when do they stay at around age 60 plus
so at a time when we are biologically
and evolutionarily not selected for
I see and firstly I really like your
analogy um I think I'm gonna have to
fill that at some point too
um but it's also
um what's going to ask you
um so clearly there's a lot about
senescent cells that we so don't fully
understand
um what
um and in particular it's understanding
the acute versus like chronic long-term
senescence and so there's a lot of mouse
models now that use like p16 as a
reporter to sort of identify and locate
senescent cells but what in terms of
tool development do you think we need
and what are the sort of questions that
we should really be trying to address in
this in essence field
yeah so
um there are now many stories for
instance that are focusing on p21
senescent as opposed to p16 lessons
right so there's already a clear
distinction in Tools in that direction
but I think we need subtype specific
tools for instance
um like I said for for this guard cells
or the il-1 high cells here we are
trying to make reporters that would not
just kill all senescent cells because
that's a sledgehammer right and I think
if you kill all senescent cells in the
human body at some point it will have
all sorts of that that in itself creates
uh inflammation right so you would
create all sorts of chronic diseases
because of that
I think if you if you know let's say
ufcs is in your kidney and I have it in
my aortic Arch then you may need a
different specific compound to only
Target that subtype of senescent cells
than I do for instance so we need tools
that this first of all we need spatial
tools to map
which types of in essence are which
disease and and which organ
second of all we need
um
real-time reporters because we don't
know if that cell that secretes il-6
today and I let's say the neighboring
cell does not does this switch the other
way around next day nobody's ever
documented that and we do know that some
of these factors can have a circadian
rhythm depending on your sleep cycles
they can actually change so these are
all things that should be investigated
much better with so spatial reporters
temporal reporters and then Niche
specific Inhibitors like the the compass
we are making
so we've spoken a lot now about uh
cellular lessen Essence but that's just
one of the Hallmarks of aging and so
um would you be able to elaborate on you
know how much do you think senescence is
contributing to aging and what are your
thoughts and these other potential
Hallmarks in the process
right so there are now 9 or 13 depending
on the paper you read Hallmarks for
eating right and um so then the question
is to what extent that have they all
been proven or was it mostly an
association
I do think for senescence the evidence
is very strong there are like I said at
least
but I think at least 40 papers showing
that if if you remove certain cells in
mice you have better benefits so that's
beyond the doubt is proved in contrast
some of the other specs like the
mitochondrial uh Ross Theory of Aging
has likely been debunked right so we now
know if you create oxidative stress
about the community actually you don't
get a lot of pro-aging phenotypes so
what do I I what do I think is promising
well obviously dietary restriction and
dietary sexual mimetics like rap logs
Etc we've known for two Millennia
actually already that eating not too
much and then you know doing your
exercise is good for you sits are
already wrote about this uh you know
2000 years ago
but it's also a little bit predictable
in that sense and the most dietary
advice books are based around this area
so out of the new quote-unquote
directions of course stem cell
regeneration is the big hit at this
point
so if you put yamanaka factors to make
uh you know to reprogram differentiating
cells to become stem cells again and if
you do that transiently this has amazing
effects on Aging
um so I think that's also why there are
several companies now being founded
around that idea
um yeah I think this is very promising
so I think those three for me
are at this point the strongest so I
always wonder what if you would combine
them and it's still a bit of a dream of
mine if I have enough money to do a
mouse experiment where you say we
couldn't first in dietary restriction
and then when they start to age you give
them an anti-ness treatment and then
when that doesn't happen you you start
doing stem cell reprogramming and if
that's exhausted you start implanting
new organs right so you can also still
nowadays ex-vivo culture whole organs
and and you know there's lots of
exciting stuff going on in that
direction so these are my three
favorites of course pros and toxicity is
a very strong epigenetic remodeling but
that's mostly done in lower organisms
quote-unquote and the verdict is still
out there to what extent this is
reproducible in in higher mammals so to
say
given what you just said then in terms
of like I guess envisioning the future
of healthcare do you see a sort of
rational approach where depending on
your stage of life you might be offered
different uh treatment options and that
maybe the sort of be safer um
Therapeutics would be applied fast and
if that's not effective then you sort of
progress to the more attention yeah I
think this is how cool would that be
right I mean so dietary restriction does
not work over age 70. in fact it has the
opposite outcome so if you take elderly
and you they should actually gain muscle
mass not reduce muscle mass so all
geriatricians I speak to say yeah this
is a nice result in mice had this
dietary restriction but I will never do
it in the clinic so they actually have
to provide excess protein to elderly so
I think dietary restriction works until
let's say age 50 60 something like that
until the point you start getting
senescent cells right and then you might
come in with your anti-senescent therapy
and then of course I don't know when but
this steps or replacement you can you
can argue if you have cells which are
you know extremely damaged you might as
well reactivate their stem cell
machinery and that comes along with a
lot of DNA repair mechanisms so you
would revert some of the damaged cells
to that the downside is I don't know
what would happen with let's say
memories right that's my big fear if you
you for a lot of tissues you might you
might not care if you rejuvenate a liver
or a lung or a kidney but your brain
it's a different game altogether right
which you lose memories if you uh you
know make stem cells out of your neurons
again let's say oh yeah
yeah that's a potential Pitfall which
you would never know you wouldn't have
known if you're losing memories right
unless you start to getting dementia
then it's extreme but yeah so I think
you're right we will depending on the
phase of life and also depending on your
main weakness like a car
there's usually one piece of your of
your car that breaks down each year
right it's not it's not like the whole
thing uh dies out
and then maybe something else throughout
the the lifetime of the car right the
engine and there's a transmission and
energy tires etc etc with our bodies I
think it's the same this year you'll
liver next year maybe your kitten
whatever so depending on what it is you
might get different therapies and yeah I
think right now we're still considering
aging too much as one that's as if we
age all in the same way we don't
that yeah exactly
um and one thing he also made me think
of just then was again going back to p53
which clearly my mind so I was thinking
about
um in terms of cellular Library
programming it's been shown that I'll
say p53 is one of the things that sort
of antagonizes the reprogramming process
and I know that's why you wrote a brief
commentary on discussing p53 as being
both pro-aging but also Pro longevity
and so it's therefore p53 like the most
important protein to be studying in
terms of Aging research
I'm not going to say the most important
Protein that's a bit much maybe but uh
it's it's absolutely yeah I would say
fun but also a very important protein
because it has so many roles so you can
steer it in so many directions what you
often see in nowadays in research is
that you either do massive over
expression or you take it out right so
it's either all on or all off but I
think with p53 it's a very important way
which direction you push it towards
right and that's why I think B3 is so
exciting to work with because our
compounds do not blunt all p53 activity
right it only steers One Direction I
don't know how it relates to stem survey
program that's not my field of expertise
I don't know how it blocks reprogramming
but you're right indeed if you repress
DNA repair in general you seem to be
getting better reprogramming
um in all fairs I'm not the person to
comment on that but because I'm not I'm
not an expert on that area but I think
it's uh also maybe something to consider
if you can temporarily manipulate DNA
damage repair to get better uh
reprogramming and then switch it back on
might be very interesting yeah
yeah no I think there's so many
interesting
um questions like the biological
questions still to address I'd say to
kind of wrap up a really interesting
discussion I was just wondering if you
could
um share some like lessons that you've
learned throughout your career so far um
or like some advice that you would give
for younger researchers who are trying
to sort of navigate this new yet but
exciting fields
yeah so I think um you know SS I always
tell every student
um science is a field where you need to
motivate yourself right so first you
need to pick something you are
interested in that if you need to do
this on a Saturday night when everybody
hits the pub and you feel like the
amazing you're able to do it so that's
that's if you're doing something you're
not quite sure and that's that's natural
and no this doesn't start overnight so
you have to gradually build an interest
in something and for me
it all came together in in this company
like I started as a molecular biologist
and then I started doing some cell
biology work and then I started doing a
mice and then I was like oh let's
combine it all so it's not like you have
to know this tomorrow
I think you should also you know be
original
that's what I try to do I I'm go I'm
always kind of going against the stream
running a stream
appetized people didn't believe in
peptides I still tried it anyway and it
worked so I think as a scientist we have
a habit anyway of uh being a bit cowboy
so I think uh there's nothing wrong with
that and
um you have to find the department that
supports that kind of attitude it's like
if you are in a department with only
nature papers count
that is also of course important your
academic track record but for me this
now is no longer the higher goal so I I
of course I acknowledge the need to
publish
but I my my career I now made a declare
this disconnect I uh I I think papers
don't cure patients right drugs do so uh
for me uh I get happy when my drug hits
the clinic then I move on to something
else and my my department supports that
so I don't need to publish a major paper
every year to do this but for instance
so that's easier to set them done
because it doesn't always work like that
around the world
hey I think you should start with
something you're super interested in and
try to become one of the best in that
particular area and don't copy others in
that sense just try to become original
and be you know try to work towards
really solving a main question you know
don't just do the small question that
everybody else does but think out of the
box easier said than done I acknowledge
but that is in the end the fun part I
think of science yeah exactly and I
agree I think it is definitely easier
said than done but it's also really good
advice and something that I do try to
think about myself
um like think about the question and
what tools can I use to address it and
make the most impact
so um why could I direct my fears that
they want to learn more about your
research
yeah yeah one step back still sorry
don't always let it be your strong
points
of course it's important to work on your
weak points as well but you know you
will always be recognized for your
strongest asset
so that's one advice
um yeah actually that's the main advice
I want to get and where people and then
where people where they can find more
about the research you ask yeah or
um well obviously we communicate quite a
bit through uh the website of of Clear
Eye itself
um
and in English not so much actually I
have a lot of uh interviews in in Dutch
but that's those won't get you very far
uh outside of the middle so we do have a
website on the University Medical Center
uh homepage that there's that you can
find and other than that we are a little
bit slow on publishing because we want
to yeah publish less that's also My
Philosophy not everybody's supported but
I think we should publish way less and
and you know more complete stories that
we fully understand as opposed to
contaminating the field
so um less more but we will be
submitting something soon so okay
exciting um so yeah say best of luck um
with your research I'm with Clara and
I'll definitely be on the Lookouts um
when new announcements come out and
thank you for taking the time to speak
with me and explaining everything so
clearly it's been a great fun
likewise I I fully wish you the best
with this exciting uh set of interviews
thank you so I hope you've learned
something in this video thank you to my
patreon supporters and thank you for
listening